I am the reason behind the success of
your production and I'll tell you why
your uh co-star Bobby um ran out there
was a shortage of um Aderall like a
national shortage ofal right when he was
the first week of filming and I think he
World War Z everyone was out in the
streets going crazy dude like I mean I
do you not remember like what a mess he
was and then I was able to score some I
don't remember how it might have been
let's just maybe it was from across the
border was it my mom it was your
mom this show is sponsored by betterhelp
therapy helps you find your strength so
you can ditch the extreme resolutions
and make changes that really stick
celebrate the progress you've already
made visit betterhelp.com TR Tuesday
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com Tuesday Helix is offering 20% off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
Tuesday and use code Helix partner2 this
is their best offer yet and it will not
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now slugs happy New Year January 18th in
Portland and then I'll be in Seattle
January 26th you can get tickets at
esteron ice.com hey sluggy I can't wait
to meet you I can't wait to perform for
you my set is so good if I say so myself
a little cocky but I think I've earned
it
come see me you can see me next January
12th and 13th in Edmonton you can see me
February 16th and 17th in Denver
Colorado um doing Annie wood and Friends
February
20th um February 21st and 22nd I'm in
Vancouver March 1st and 2nd I'm in
Fortworth Texas I will be in Albuquerque
New Mexico I'm coming back to New Mexico
guys I'm so excited that's March 8th and
9th um at the end of March I'll be in
Washington DC and May 9th I will be in
Los Angeles at the Netflix fil uh the
Netflix is a joke festival and and then
in June end of June I will be in
Jacksonville Florida I'm sorry I had to
chose those dates and you can see me
every Thursday on
annwood you guys welcome back to trash
Tuesday I know we had a guest last week
and it was already
2024 but this is our cozy our family our
official New Year's Eve I'm I'm sorry
not new year year
new New Year we're moving to New York
it's our official um kickoff to 202 for
episodes yes yes what does that really
mean I wonder do you okay every year
before New Year's I'm like all right
like this you know it's going to be the
year everything's going to be different
and then you wake up and it's the new
year and you finally wish fished your
wish it's all the same you fished your
wish [__] what do you mean this is
going to be a very different year for
you but I mean like the first few days
of January the first few weeks I'm like
I struggle to feel different I don't
have a problem with the first few days
or few weeks it's the weeks after that
it's cuz I I will have that like New
Year's push and then you just slowly
fall back into your habits and are like
there's I'm not doing this but I don't
know semi glutide is changing my life
guys I don't even get the push like I
wake up you have the push I don't I have
chronic fatigue and um pots I have can
you explain me what pots is cuz I kind
of just laugh in your face when you say
it because it sounds so stupid it's
postural orthostatic Tachi cardia
syndrome so what happens is basically
like I can be sat down like this right
you can take my blood pressure and you
can take my heart rate my heart rate
will probably be in the lower 60s and my
blood pressure will be about uh 110 over
80 say for inst okay I don't know what
those things mean do you know which is
normal all normal I'm just saying it's
normal and then I stand up my blood
pressure drops extremely low to like 80
over 50 which is really low and my my
heart rate go up to like 150 and I get
very laded every time you stand up um
probably eight out of 10 times so we
need to get you a walker but apparently
it's like a symptom of not to start the
new year on a grim note but it's a
symptom of chronic um PTSD I'm sorry um
complex pts because your internal system
is like so yeah my body is just like
burnt out and that's why I have like
chronic fatigue is one of the other
symptoms of it because I I'm telling you
guys yes I work out it's a [__]
miracle I work you work out a lot and
you don't a miracle that I do because
when I'm not working out I want to be
horizontal all day I am so tired we want
you horizontal too I would definitely
then understand pregnancy very well can
I see the AC that's I I will force
myself to work out but I really it's
really hard and I want to be laying down
all the time did you not feel that way
before not as much I we'll be honest I
am reaching that point in the pregnancy
where that belly induced insomnia is
starting that I've read so much about on
Reddit late at night like basically it's
a little bit harder to get comfortable
and I know it's only going to get harder
so I'm trying to stay calm usually we've
had that but with like the bellies of
the fat men we're sleeping
with so I am just like really tired I
think I'm like and I I hate to like be
at work and be like I'm tired but that's
just like that's what work is for I'm
sorry can we normalize this who's not
complain about being tired at work ever
and that's what work is you just look to
someone next to go I'm tired oh I don't
I don't I don't know really I think yes
I mean when you ask a cooworker like how
are you doing and someone says I'm great
I'm having the best day ever it's you
know that's not commiserating we're all
[__] tired the end of that's the
thing is everyone is tired so no one
wants to hear you complain that you're
tired is your insomnia like an anxiety
no it's more just like oh I'm awake now
and there is just no going back to sleep
in sight I don't know I don't know why
pregnancy get gives you insomnia because
it should in theory be making you so
tired but is it in true insomnia or is
it that you're feeling like physical
symptoms that keep you up and like
you're like there's insomnia is like you
know is it is it a brain thing or is it
more like God my it's pushing on my
bladder I keep having to get up to pee
well that's to me that's like kind of
all connected cuz it's like oh I just
woke up cuz I'm a weird position and now
I'm awake and you can't go back down you
can't go back to sleep easily do you
have that when you're not pregnant yeah
actually I do yeah it's if I wake up at
like 4:00 a.m. I'm like the day is
starting I guess this sucks Dave will be
at Sleep Till 1 p.m. I suggest never
getting an AA ring why because I will
sleep a like I'll wake up and be like oh
I got a good night's sleep and then you
check and it's like no you didn't you
got no deep sleep you got no REM and
then you go it's like your efficiency
like your your daily efficiency is you
need to take you need to take it easy
today I'm like what it also tells me to
go to sleep at 9:00 p.m. I'm like uh
they're like you're winding down I'm
like I'm just getting started ring I
have a question for you my Ring's trying
to Alpha me I'm like no [__] no no no
no no you know this is interesting to me
do you think you're just overriding your
systems like your your system is saying
one thing but your brain is being like
no like I'm taking over like I'm just
overriding whatever that is the ring I I
actually believe the ring is telling me
the truth and I am like but I have
learned coping skills to decide that I
am alert and awake okay so this is a
it's funny that this is coming up
because I this is like a realization I
made this week in pregnancy is like
pregnancy is the time where you can't
override what your body wants like if
you're a little hungry you have to eat
have okay have you guys ever gone really
long without eating like for whatever
reason maybe like 10 hours 12 hours
whatever and your stomach is so empty
that you start burping in pregnant
prancy I will go 1 minute I'll be like I
could not eat Dave like no how could you
even bring up dinner no 3 minutes later
po days 3 minutes later I'm burping I'm
like oh I need to eat I need it's like
how does that come on that fast it's so
inconvenient it's so inconvenient to be
pregnant okay my check-in is over who's
next Annie your lashes are incredible I
know they're stabbing you in the eye it
could be a serious eye infection from it
I'm gonna come in with a sty but I will
listen for my sluggy I will I will put
glue on the sty I'll have the lashes on
the lump for you are you wearing the
same eyes Shadow it looks different yeah
I feel like it
looks maybe like a fairy princess on you
it's pretty fairy princess I think you
we can't tell on ourselves I think it's
because Annie has some on her cheek as
well I put it all over yeah and you
don't so she's glowing I'll put it on my
tits I'll put it everywhere I'm just
ugly smack on my labia let's go baby
it's New Year what you're always
beautiful
I feel good I woke up at 6:30 in the
morning with ease same and I feel bad
with ease but I I didn't have a spot
last night and I'm all of the like
vitamins and stuff I've been taking and
the peptides the semi glutide and
everything has been like regulating
everything like I'm falling asleep at a
normal hour really like I even think if
I was yeah cuz when I had a spot the
other night I still went to bed like at
12: which is earlier than I usually go
to bed and it's so hard to go to sleep
after you perform it's you're you and
here's the thing too like my spot the
other night was at 10:00 at 8: I was
like cannot wait to perform and then by
by like 9:50 I was like I'm the most
tired I've ever been in my life so then
I'm like chugging a Red Bull I'm like I
got to get up I got to perform and then
I'm like I perform and then I'm like
Zing you know it's really the cruelest
thing I know last two weeks ago I'm like
I love our job but like the fact that we
get amped up at night how do we have a
regular it's hard to have a regular like
whenever I talk to these like longevity
doctor sarus um this might be out of
this might not be relatable but um
they're always like you need sleep you
need sleep and it's like okay well your
Sarcan Rhythm my sarum rhythm is never
going to be at the right place I'm never
going to be able to go to sleep early
and wake up early it's like that's not
what my job is so I don't know I'm
always trying to figure that out but
okay so you woke up early it did it I it
was easy I went to bed I woke up early I
have to give Randy this little like
vitamin in the morning I've been getting
that done handling his little vitamin
early
then I went are you guys seen the same
longevity doctor yes we are I give him a
little bit for me a little bit I'm
giving him um semi glutide yeah he's on
OIC he's down 60 lbs it's shocking he's
only5 pounds now he looks so good so hot
sorry to say that in front of you Kila I
know my dogs are not um very they cute
though you dress them up you know I'm
really I was hoping for a um a more
enthusiastic response when I sent you
guys the Christmas picture of my
I was so into that I felt like I got up
off the toilet I saw that I stood up
from the toilet I wiped whatever I
needed to wipe and I go Dave where's
donut Christmas dress front or back I
don't remember and we went into her
little cubby and we got out all her
Christmas outfits and unfortunately none
of them fit this year but um would you
like some puppos zpic I have some
they're in ry's fridge we have a special
fridge for ry's bragging about it really
triggered me um okay so you woke up
early woke up early did my thing um went
to
Pilates but which was actually a mistake
because I went three days I went to yoga
two days Pilates yesterday I needed a
day off my body was too tired I was kind
of like okay this hurts too much um
should have taken a break that's a good
note for the future I went to the coffee
shop I got Kila her shirt oh my God you
did this was they had two colors two
like versions of this was the best
colors let's see oh that's so cute you
know I'm going to look like incredible
this thank so you're going to look great
in it I thought you going to say look
bad I was like no no no like I always
look really good in yes of course you
look good everything I've never heard so
nice about herself I know she's getting
um I'm uncomfortable I like it no I love
it she's healthy up but don't ask her to
stand up pass on out yeah might pass
away do you fall to the ground I learned
i' so I've had it since I was like
pretty young so I very careful now or
just you know what it is I just override
my systems I just keep walking until I
fall off the starting block sewing no no
did you get dizzy in the water ever no
it's only from getting up and down you
know my brother okay so my twin brother
has Tourette's I don't know if I've
talked about this and when we were on
the swim team he used to always get
disqualified because he'd be spinning
they'd be like Lane four can you please
take your marks and he'll be like
spinning and then underwater he would
get disqualified cuz in the dive if he
would spin underwater like a little
dolphin oh my God so
cute having so much fomo right now that
I can't override my systems that's like
the most fun is when you override your
systems when you like you know you're
tired yes and you like drugs yeah so
like that's the first time I learned to
override the systems because when I was
like in my late teens everyone was like
if you sleep past like if you take
ambian but you just fight it oh yeah
yeah yeah and then you get into this
like Twilight Zone and that was like the
most pleasurable like anal experience I
ever had was on Twilight ambient I
should have known Twilight ambient be
called because the first time I had anal
I I swore to never do it again I had a
fever that night I was like oh I think I
was just so traumatized by whole is the
shape is the color of Twilight you know
fading a fading Darkness thought you're
going to see a pale
vampire the first 10 minutes of a
colonoscopy are the no the first first
10 seconds are the best of your life cuz
they give you Twilight yes which I
forgot what Twilight what well now they
give you propop fall which is a Michael
Jackson drug yeah and you just for 10
seconds you're like it's the best High
Ever well I really enjoyed getting my
wisdom teeth out cuz the Laughing Gas
rolled I was like this is the greatest
I've ever
felt on on Twilight ambient also okay
ambient doesn't make you actually sleep
though right like aren't you like not
like fulfilling your like need like it
I'm not sure I never took for to
actually sleep I took it because my mom
had it I was like oh I'm going to
experiment with this and then one time I
took it and I I sleep eight like I woke
up with crumbs all over my body and like
a stacks of PL but this is when I was
like extreme dieting and I was not
eating any carbs and Atkins was thing
just giving you what your body needs
like Roseanne did not want to be on that
show anymore so like it gave her that
tweet that she she tweeted out so she
didn't have to keep going on set yeah it
really does give you what your body
I just don't I like I had a friend who
like prescribed it to me I don't know
prescri and then she like wanted some
back and then she wanted some back you
know what I mean I was like I don't know
if that's legal she was like give me
half of that I was like we don't hang
out anymore but um but she was like she
was like it's great and I was like I
don't I've never like woken up feeling
refreshed and ready to go off of ambient
yeah because oh so you have taken it you
have to get the eight hours that's why
and you're probably getting five yeah
it's not yeah and if you do not get the
full eight you're a zombie you wake up
very very groggy you're still in it wait
let's get a Kila check in okay anal amb
you have you've had anal ambian no when
I take ambient I shove it right up my
ass I boof it I only boof ambient guys
listen my [__] is awake a lot and
that is it is actually I would say the
most awake part of my body is my [__]
really what was it about the ambient um
I know because if it just to sleep
through
it finally fing sleep through it have
you had boyfriends where like you can
just want him asleep okay so this is a
discussion let's put a pin in that
because I absolutely want to talk about
this [__] right here anyways my
check in here goes my checkin okay my
checkin I just want to be clear and I
will forfeit the rest of my checkin but
I still was still in bed and I hadn't
gotten even close to it but that was
seven 6:30 when I woke up but guys I'm
going to Forfeit it because we don't
have the whole show for me to do my
check-in okay thank you but I feel great
I did my NAD again I feel good and I
didn't throw up um my check-in um this
is the first day I'm taking creatine and
I feel pretty like you know like I've
always so my mom is an uh she's really
been very proud of the fact that she's a
natural gym girly her whole life she has
acquired a 16 pack and has been ripped
her whole life and she's always like I
don't take anything I just nourish my
body with food and blah blah blah and
I've always kind of stuck with that I've
never taken a single supplement
and but I saw this like doctor on Tik
Tok who is like per she's talking about
per menopause and menopause and she was
like see is that now my algorithm is
just giving me menopause stuff
constantly I like it and hot like
six-year-old ladies yeah so I took
creatine and then I I I worked out and I
looked at my body in the mirror and I
was like oh my God I'm like swole I need
to chill out for a little bit Yeah
because it fills your muscles up with
like water and it you know it helps with
like ATP and all that stuff okay what is
what does it do like is this safe is it
like it's one of the most one of the
safest supplements I think and longest
studed right it's an actual your body
naturally creates it and you're just
kind of boosting your own what made you
decide all of a sudden to start it the
per menopause lady oh but it's also good
for your brain it just kind of like I'm
very very low energy so I'm taking
things that are I think might help like
I'm taking magnesium threonate I'm
taking things that are boosting me a
littleit been Tak magnesium to is
supposed to be good for like brain fog
and stuff I thought you said at night
magnesium um glycinate I take at night
that's what I'm taking at night because
of you and then also magnesium citrate
occasionally for constipation but I will
also sorry to interrupt your update but
I will come forward that I've been doing
suppositories every morning oh fun I
love suppository I love putting them up
thing I had to do that you did yeah but
when and then they didn't work and then
I popped a thing and went to the
hospital have you ever tried a [__] so
hard that you went to the hospital
yes and you're trying to override your
system I'm using the brand Fleet it's
actually Whitney gave it to me she's
like here take this which is a funny
like drug to get from a friend but she
gave me this little tub and you just
stick it up your butt and then you kind
of just chill out and then a few minutes
later like you got that urge to purge
the party starts yeah I love
suppositories wait are there any
negative side effects to creatine I'm
like so I think you have to have like
good kidney function like you have to
make sure your kidneys are are good okay
anything you take you make sure your kid
I'm so jealous of your guys's like
supplemental glowup Journeys while I'm
over here just likeing getting pregnant
using trying to [__] well we're figuring
out how you can have your bounce back
okay that's true I'm studying and we
have two options You Can Get Swole or
you can lose all your muscle
mass which I'm very I'm very worried
about I am working out more yeah it's
easier to work out it's so weird I
literally don't want to lose weight they
have to make you're the first person to
go on zic that doesn't want to lose
weight I'm literally like they have to
make it so that you don't lose weight
they have to give you one that's cuz I'm
telling you it fixed whatever made me
think that I was fat that's incredible
are you what's your hunger situation
like are you eating yeah I'm eating I'm
trying to get as much protein they say
You're supposed to get protein for like
as many pounds as you have which is
almost impossible unless I'm doing like
so many protein shakes but I'm trying to
just eat a lot of protein cuz I don't
want to lose mus but you can still eat
you're not like disgusted by food I
think yeah I don't know if when you get
low higher doses or whatever or if it's
people are eating like greasy food I I
don't eat unhealthy food so what are
your um do you guys set goals for the
new year or is it just the same like you
know goals that carry into the next year
from last year what I really like to do
at the beginning of the year which I
haven't done it this year yet and I
always say like I give myself the whole
month you know January like that's the
whole grace period yeah if I get
inspired maybe I won't maybe I don't but
like you get a new notebook and you just
kind of like write down your goals write
down what right what do you I have
rollover notebooks I have so many
notebooks I've never touched what do you
what about you what do you guys do I do
rollover I do roll over I just more
concretely it's like the same goals but
I just more concretely State them yeah
and set your intentions for the year I
was really good about this last year and
then once I got pregnant like I just
fell off year before I think you wanted
us to cancel news you were like I'm done
with this it's too much pressure yeah
wait was that but that's where cuz I had
a good start to the year I don't I don't
maybe you just needed to say that and
then you like restarted cuz I do think I
think the best thing for the new year
rather than like even thinking forward
is to like release things that I like I
no longer want to do this yeah so that
goes into what I had first which is all
about last year Stella's like I do this
work can you please look at it yeah like
by the way guys there's always like all
these notes Stella puts up I literally
don't see words reading is like so
foreign to me that I don't it's like it
could be
it's more of an outline yeah what are
three words that you would use to
describe last year 2023 New York New
York for me it would be New York
pregnancy maybe love Fleet enemas maybe
Love Actually oh Esther that's already a
movie [__] hack because when Dave and
I went to New York together that was
like I feel like we really I don't know
it was just like getting to date a guy
who like has an apartment in New York
like it was a whole new relationship be
dating in New York feels so romantic so
crazy New York makes me so horny like
when I'm in New York I'm I literally
walk down the streets and I hug the I
hug New York it got me pregnant I spin
wait this is a really good point because
the last time I was in New York I was so
jetlagged and so out of my [__] mind
I didn't know what time it was CU I went
straight from the Philippines to New
York and but like I just myself every
single day while I was there and it was
you have to find like a hot young I
didn't have the energy for that oh the
coffee shop guy I remember I I just
remember just going like you're so hot
and it was just on he was fingering me
in like a a van outside of my spot so
love love nework and pregnancy I just
was like it set me up for like a good
Rhythm and then I got the pregnancy got
me really sick but um yeah those are
those would be like my three big themes
does feel behind you though because it's
over and you're having like more
positive feelings no it does not feel
behind me
because scared about what the postpartum
is going to be like that could hit and
it could be like way worse is what a lot
for a lot of people it is but yeah those
are my three and I think there's good
things in there too so what about you
guys Esther I think it's I like that
you're very honest about it I feel like
not enough people are we don't care if
you complain about it this is not a real
this is not real work this is like I
don't want to like out as these walls
are fake guys this is like totally fake
but my best friend was the same way and
I was I was like thank you like there
was no not one good positive thing she
said I she's like I don't even care that
there's a baby in there either there's a
r there's a range there's a variation
it's like there's different people have
different experience and you would think
that because I've had pregnancy loss
that I would be like I'm so grateful I'm
and I am but like I'm just it's
reallying physically hard and I had I
think I have like prenatal depression
that I'm starting stting to come out of
and working on what is prenatal
depression before you have it everyone
talks about postpartum depression but
yeah exactly it's just but prenatal is
still when they're in it's there it's
before so maybe I'll have postpartum
happiness you kind of don't seem
depressed though you're kind of crushing
it and you're just like think of like
what you're going through like how you
would have been not pregnant if you were
having these ailments you would have
been I do think you're still there's
like gratitude sprink yeah there is
there is like now that I can feel the
baby move like that is really exciting
and I do like whenever Dave expresses
how grateful he is that like gets I get
so high off of that I'm like I'm doing
this for someone else like I'm
sacrificing for like it just makes me
feel like a way I've literally never
felt cuz I've never done that
before um your what was your favorite
memory of 2023 Annie give us three words
to describe your year snakes snakes
snakes I love my snakes we're getting a
new snake baby there's an albino pine
snake we got a name we're excited no I
like I don't know i' I've had so much
fun like I've had um iasa
snakes I don't know everything's falling
together I think I'm shedding a lot of
things maybe use the snake analogy I'm
I'm shedding some skins I feel like so
confident I feel really good and I feel
like yeah every day I just get a little
bit more my true Essence my
getting back to like who you are but
like the who I am that I didn't even
haven't known yet it's exciting just
like not giving a [__] what people think
just being I think I always because I
had a twin brother I always who was so
much smaller than me like I just I just
robbed him in the womb like I took
everything like he was like a shrimp and
I was like this big baby I think I've
just always been afraid of like
outshining or whatever like so I just am
never like my fullest I kind of like
tamper and I don't feel like I don't
feel like I like dim and it could be the
highlighter but I'm not dimming myself
anymore I'm being like as shiny as
possible is that because like so you
came out bigger and then when you were
little were people like was your family
like like about that maybe a little bit
but it's like I just had more I mean I
just like I just had more re I stole
like I guess maybe that's a story about
it but I mean it's definitely a story
about it but it's I was just bigger than
him and better at sports a little cuter
you know I just he's a some guy you know
he does all right and uh his wife's
gorgeous but you're the hottie of the
family I'm the hot yeah I'm the hottie I
mean Max got it Max got it but he had to
work on his personality a little bit to
over the nose on me was like a little
cuter a hot girl no matter what is
always hotter than a hot guy but I think
like my shininess got me in trouble as a
kid you know the word we shall not say
on camera because for some reason that
gets demonetized that's fuing weird
crazy but uh you know the diddling and
stuff and I think I just like have been
like trying to not be too much but I'm
just being also you know what like don't
underestimate the like last 10 years of
what life in society has been where when
we post things and random people say you
suck you're ugly like that'll dim you
too and I think it's time this year 2024
for us toing break through that and come
out of it and be ourselves and because I
think that's affected all of us remember
what I was saying to you in there too
it's like it's like if someone doesn't
like our out like if someone doesn't
like my outfit you have bad tasting
outfits like I know what's cool like
it's me like I am the set designer and
the and the costume designer in my movie
you are not you are watching my movie
with popcorn [__] so like learn from me
and get a cute outfit yeah it's m we're
designing our lives and what we're doing
and and I'm just really inspired by what
you're saying it's like the most
important thing of this year should be
like let's get back to who are we really
and the even who are we really that we
haven't met yet there's this guy I
should try to find the the real but
there's this guy who's like a
motivational speaker and he dresses like
insane I don't know if it's to trigger
people on purpose but I I I want to give
him a shout out but I don't know what
his name is but he is giving the seminar
and he goes to someone who goes hey if
someone came up and said your hair is
blue would you be like oh my hair is BL
like oh no he's like it's like in it's
like it's just not true you just have to
not believe in it's just like shut the
up maybe with less anger but yeah Kila
three words three words um um I'm having
some memory loss like this is the first
year where I was this is going to sound
really strange but after I did ketamine
the year before um I don't know if
ketamine does this but I've I'm
forgetting a lot of things in my life
but I think that I needed to forget it
and I'm actually coping a lot better
because of some level of memory loss
like my family have always been the
elephant someone who just never forgets
names never forgets dates never forgets
events bad things good things that
happen and I think that has been a
detriment to to me because I hang on to
things beautiful like and now I'm just
like oh like early onset Alzheimer's
cool no beautiful Kila you're dropping
you're dropping memories that you don't
need to sleep the past you're not on to
the past that's amazing yeah so I think
2023 was um definitely a year of a whole
lot of necessary memory loss and just um
kind of like what I felt was the ability
to just put one foot in front of the
other without looking back so much I'm
trying to break out of a box I think
I've placed myself in for so long which
is like I've only done podcasts this is
who I am now like I'm never going to do
do stand up obviously it's not my Lane
I'm never going to do this but I have
kept myself in this very like safe place
of like I've been doing you know just
I'm a podcaster I do this I've been
doing it for nearly a decade but then
2023 was like you know what [__] like
like you had you were a kid that wrote
down too many things on your list of
dreams of list of things you wanted to
accomplish I was like why don't you go
look at that again and so I have and you
know I'm excited to say 2024 is going to
be a really big year of me just trying
to venture into very scary but big
projects and I'm really really proud of
myself are we allowed to talk about your
thing I think soon yeah I've put my
heart and soul into something that I
feel super excited and passionate about
and I think I've done an incredible job
and I'm really like looking forward to
like having people share in on that this
year I know just knowing you like when
you do something you do an incredible
job at it like really impressive and I'm
so inspired and excited to hear that you
are stepping out of just podcaster
because I do understand when you have a
job it's really easy for that to become
your whole identity you're like that's
what I do that's my thing and there's
some good to that but then we can get
too stuck in it and so I'm so happy that
you're like having The Bravery to step
outside of that and like try something
new which is so scary your brain doesn't
want you to but you just are so good at
what you do like you say you're going to
do something you kill it and so I'm I
know a little bit about what you're
talking about and I can't wait to share
it with and I've really desperately try
to not shed but like like I've honored
the last decade of my life with Bobby
but I am more than just his
ex-girlfriend I was more than that
before I met him and I will continue to
be more than that after him like you
know we yes I am I have a close
relationship with my ex but like dude I
was a complex layered onion well before
that I would have been in a place of
success with or without him and I think
that people tried to take that away from
me and say you wouldn't have been [__]
without him iing absolutely would have
you did not and if you don't if you
didn't know me before that before Bobby
you wouldn't maybe know but I was always
going to get here also you wouldn't have
seen him on a podcast without her I know
but also K the more you do like outside
of podcasting the better it's going to
be for podcasting because this does get
like to be lot like just talking you
have so it's like we're we have multiple
podcasts it's like there's like a lot of
you're like okay it's like the more we
do outside the better it is for everyone
I think so too and and I I will say it
again I I was always going to get here I
was always going to work hard be
ambitious and and be about the bag and
set off to achieve my dreams like I've
never not been that girl about the bag
that is New Year's resolution be about
the B well I love this theme it's like
we're all investing in ourselves in
different ways and we're going to be
going off and living our lives and all
that's going to do is let us come back
to the to our show every week and just
have more life experience to share like
you're going to be probably like T
sharing about how being an entrepreneur
you know like that's going to be so
interesting to hear hopefully people
will be okay that one of us has a baby
and then that'll be of course give us
some hugg money baby o we're happy to
pimp that baby out can we pimp baby out
and motherhood out though of course God
this has been so much suffering I need
something out of it are you kidding no
no this baby will make us all rich all
of us all of us even you at home um you
know what I was thinking though there is
a danger with I think like New Year's
resolutions too for myself where it's
like I have been realizing so much about
how you know I I know that being in the
past is bad but I'm being so much in the
future too I'm really robbing myself of
the present moment and I'm putting a lot
of pressure on myself where it's like
it's more like I I used to think my all
of my goals need to be so specific and I
think that is like what me up and it's
like more about having grander things
about like abundance and happiness
rather than specific goal posts I need
to hit so it's more of like a feeling
and a vibe that I can embody now rather
than feeling like oh well if I want this
specific thing I don't have it right now
and it's like hard to oops is that a
good sign wait no I actually I'm like
trying to interpret that cuz I'm getting
two things from it and I really like it
are you it's like okay you instead of
being like I need this x specific goal
it's like I actually just need to feel
this certain way about my life right and
then all of those things come in it's
almost like thinking too small anyway I
actually wanted to bring this up earlier
when we were talking about
exercise I learned from Dr Ruben who is
an allergist who you have to follow okay
I learned that people can be allergic to
exercise how is that possible it's a New
Year's
Miracle the world is working out for you
you can use this as an excuse don't say
working out is triggering no but
apparently it can like create like a
histamine response and cause people even
all the way in rare rare occasions like
anaxes you don't have that she work she
exercises that is my worst fear because
although I will admit that I do think
walking is working now and I will fight
that to the death people who don't think
so absolutely is there's a lot of people
who don't think that walking counts as a
workout a lot on this couch no no no I'm
just kidding but you don't not work out
yeah so basically it can trigger a
histamine response cause rash and
swelling even death in rare cases it's
called exercise Anais and this is by Dr
Ruben on Tik Tok who I follow
like I mean I am allergic to Hawaii I
know that I the the the Flora and Fauna
yeah I can never go back to Hawaii I was
never more sick she was she was sick and
fully in a puffer jacket the entire time
andai and another thing I wanted so that
was my gift to you exercise and indu
anapilis look there I'm I'm not saying
there won't be a day where I'm going to
use that cuz look did I always
participated in gym class I had my
period every day in high school my gift
to you Annie for 2024 is I found out
that Suzanne Summers got buried in
timolin Boots what what was going to
wear my Tims I wish I had my Tims I said
timland like the [__] wait Tuesday
sum I really went back to um you really
like exercised how it is an more urban
look um I went back and watched so much
suzan Summers Instagram video her
Suzanne Summers and her husband are like
they are such goals they're so amazing
it's like her I can't believe it I'm
literally this is such a gift I mean her
family everything so beautiful so cute
so funny together what is it about her
that you love they're just so funny
she's herself she's fully herself and
her husband is like is it's like Todd
like funny with her and doing and they
tease each other but it's like just so
like in love did she ever have a reality
show it was a missed opportunity I'll
tell you that but she she sells products
so she would sell like do lives on her
Instagram to sell products and they were
like yeah Suzanne Summers was very much
like a legend for my mom and she and
Annie and she got why did she get buried
in it was it about knocking boots or
something no I think these a pair of I
think she was just a fan of wearing
Timberland boots but it was in reference
to their sex life yeah it's knocking
boots oh oh it was so amazing so cute so
funny so cute you know they like till
the very end I know and not like you
know how it's like I keep thinking about
it it's like men just like are going to
be creepy old men unless they find like
the right
match of a partner that's like age
appropriate is you know where like this
like this like this guy they would make
little references each other it's not
creep it's like the you have to have the
right match like if if Suzanne Summers
was like 40 years younger than him we'd
be like this is the most disgusting yeah
I often think about like you know Esther
you talk about Jeff Bezos and Lauren
Sanchez and I think they're probably
super horned up for each other oh my God
it's so obvious is their age the same
are same not that far they're very close
I love I'm like obsessed with her
they're so they
are all the time I know I can I can see
it in the pictures like I can look at
them and be like oh this is this is what
they do in the bedroom earlier we were
talking about men or people who are like
here like if I'm sleepy you know you
have permission yeah you have permission
to like have sex with my just half
asleep body I am oh there they are oh
it's banana break they get you little
popcorn no I brought my own popcorn
today thank you Stella
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
you guys new year new problems new
Solutions I always feel like this time
of year can be super overwhelming for me
because everyone's just like raring to
go and they some people are very like
organized and these are my goals for the
year and I'm just over here like oh like
am I going to be left behind I have so
many feelings in the beginning of the
year and you know it's especially
important that I check with my therapist
and for me better help has been a game
Cher because I um don't need to worry
about finding parking driving to a
therapist I can access my therapist
through my phone through video call
through a phone call it's just flexible
convenient and like I'm not doing 2024
without the help of a therapist like I
just know that that's my that's going to
be my focus of this year and we want you
guys to celebrate the progress you've
already made visit betterhelp.com TR
Tuesday today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com Tuesday I just got my Helix
mattress and it is the best mattress
I've ever slept on um you guys know I am
a helix girl every single room in every
single house my parents house my
sister's house my friend's home we are
all Helix people I love Helix I I love
that it's as easy as taking a simple
test figuring out if you're a sid
sleeper if you're a high sleeper for
instance I have the midnight um Luxe
version and it's because I run hot in my
sleep and I wanted like a thicker
mattress and I'm telling you guys Helix
is the way to go I will not deviate from
into any other brand than Helix one of
my main New Year's resolutions is to get
enough sleep to just be getting deep
Sleep Quality sleep and it's so
important what you're sleeping on and
especially this episode we talked a lot
about the bedroom it's very important to
be comfortable day and night on your bed
imagine you're spending a third of your
life on this thing like some of us more
some of us more and that would be me no
I Lear think about you I learned about
Helix from you Kila and ever since I
switched to it I'm like oh this is great
like cuz mattresses buying them it's so
confusing like now I just know this is
the brand they have different offerings
for everyone like it's just the perfect
One-Stop shop to figure out like how to
get the best sleep Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com TR Tuesday and use code
Helix partner2 this is their best offer
yet and it won't last long with Helix
better sleep starts now I love going to
the casino I can't wait for all of my
Casino fun casino dates in 2024 but you
know what thanks to draftking casino app
I can do it at home I don't need to
waste all my money getting there I can
save it all to spend on the app I I
don't think it's any secret that um your
favorite place on on Earth is Vegas
specifically for the slots but what's
cool about DraftKings is it's not just
slots you can play Blackjack which I
love and roulette and a whole variety of
different games and if you don't want to
play with real money and you're not
ready for that yet it's not a problem
cuz the DraftKings games let you test
out the games for free to find the right
fit download the DraftKings casino app
now and use code trash Tuesday new
players get an instant deposit match up
to $100 in Casino credits when you
deposit $5 or more that's code trash
Tuesday only on DraftKings Casino the
crown is yours gambling problem call 1
1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in Connecticut
help is available for problem gambling
call 88887876774
restriction Supply one per new customer
must opt in and make minimum $5 deposit
within 7 Days 168 hours of registering
new account Max match $100 in Casino
credits which require onetime
playthrough within 7 Days 168 hours see
terms at casino. draftkings.com nplayer
offer
2024 um but what is what is your rule um
early morning um I I I I'll say mine my
engine is needs a lot of revving any
time of the day but in the morning
please do not [__] touch me unless I
have previously like approved of it the
night before but then you change your
mind no I'm not horny in the morning I'm
sorry I don't care what you do I'm not
too much of a morning I middle day but
I'm 100% anti- morning sex I think a lot
of women are except for Katie but is it
just in the beginning when things are
romantic because like years in you're
like please don't [__] touch me let
me sleep the morning she loves the
morning I think it's crazy early early
morning yeah like just when you wake up
I guess it really depends sometimes I
wake up horny and it's good and it does
such your day it's a fun day really yeah
it's a fun day but it's like I to if I
my nightmare is if I said the night
before let's bang in the morning and
then I'm like in the morning like oh God
I promised oh [__] so what I do peel
through the cottage cheese let's
go there is something about being nasty
and [__] that's the best you're right
when you're just at your nastiest okay
so my whole thing is the the guy that
I'm seeing is very much like a 530 a.m.
kind of horned up dude and I am like the
opposite of that so the compromise we
come yeah like you can bang me while I'm
asleep like don't expect me to
participate my limp body is yours but
then he's he's not into that he's like I
do not like Li bodies that's a very good
sign because my boyfriend that I said
that too took me up on it I was like no
I know I was going to say the same thing
I've pitched that and then he's like no
yeah it's not good the guys that take
you up on that you're like they're going
to be working at a morg at some point
KLA I thought you were GNA say the
compromise was like 8:30 instead of 5:30
but it was so my my horned up hours are
between the hours of 11 a.m. to 1:00
p.m. and then 400 p.m. to 7:00 p.m.
those are the times where worst hour to
have really so it's like mid mid so um
like noon around and then before right
around Sunset you day to do I know this
is why it's been it's difficult I'm like
nighttime after dinner after dinner oh
never after dinner after she goes by the
tides Okay this [__] has some stuff to
do in the water high tide low
tide do you ever bang on a boat I've
never banged on a boat I've never banged
on an airplane I've banged on a Dugout
of a baseball field yeah that is sad no
that's okay you know I have a journal I
don't know if I mentioned there I have a
journal I wish I could find it I think
it's gone forever but I had this purple
Journal when I was a kid and I wrote
what I wanted what I wanted people to
read which was like my dream journal and
then on the back was my real journal and
the fake Journal was all about like
meeting like the boys from my baseball
team up in the Dugout and like or by the
scoreboard oh my God it's funny I always
dated baseball players yeah oh by
accident like I was like not necessarily
like a CLE Chaser but I always ended up
with dudes who played baseball I think
it's okay to be a CLE Chaser if if you
want to be if you want to bang athletes
it's great you're going to have to be
cheated on probably but it's like it's a
it's a hot thing don't we agree baseball
is the hottest athlete yeah the bodies
are the hottest the thick legs so good
they do say they cheat the most though
baseball yeah because they're always
traveling yeah they have so many games
they have well over a 100 games the best
is football worst is baseball my
neighbor who was my like my young adult
adult romance novel uh protagonist his
little brother grew up to be like the
hottest baseball player it's like so
crazy I don't even know what how to look
him up but it's so weird I'm like Matt
your brother got so hot it's so [__]
weird and he got like Christian so he's
like wearing a cross and you know that's
my thing I love when a guy bangs me in
his cross hits me in his face cuz he CH
me over God why you watch Romeo and
Juliet No it's cuz he chose me for God
but yes also said that you guys back to
New Years what is something that you'd
like to accomplish or achieve or what is
like just one thing for 2024 I want to
make your baby cool no yeah it's about
you I'll say this I just realized as
we're sitting here that it's the new
year and next month my movie is coming
out and so she finally speaks about it
I'm really like I just realized oh yeah
the strike is over like I can talk about
it so I'm just like really excited
that's a new experience experience like
when does it come out I believe as of
now it's going to be coming out in
limited release in theaters February
23rd that's so that is soing exciting I
know I'm really excited it's called
drugstore June if you don't know um it
co-stars sorry Bobby
Lee
sorry and it's produced by Bill Burr and
there's like it's just yeah I'm really
excited about it so that's going to be
like a big thing I think for 2024 for me
hug and um you know who knows whatever
but I'm just excited to get it out there
have whoever however many people see it
will be exciting cuz you know I haven't
had a project that I wrote like come out
since Alone Together really I don't know
I'm just like yes okay yes a get some
estery things into the world not to too
my own horn but I feel like I am the
reason behind the success of your
production and I'll tell you why your uh
co-star Bobby um ran out there was a
shortage of umer Aderall like a national
shortage of right when he was the first
week of filming and I think Z everyone
was out in the streets going crazy dude
like I mean I do you not remember like
what a mess he was and then I was able
to score some I don't remember how it
might have been let's just maybe it was
from across the border was it my mom it
was your mom but I remember being like
you cannot be like this on set cuz he
came back like really like crying like I
can't remember my lines my brain's all
over the place and I must have called
like 50 people so I was I was the I was
drugstore that is June for you amazing
that is the thing about Aderall too it's
like when you get off of Aderall you are
like nightmare not well you are white
yeah he was he was unwell and um yeah
but you know we got through but
congratulations eser that's [__] huge
thank you and also obviously I'm this
will be the year that I become a mother
and so I have no predictions for what
that will be like and I don't want to
have any I'm just going to take it as it
comes are you going to name her
drugstore alth June is a very cute name
it is a cute name that was taken from so
my name uh I'm named after my
grandmother and then I was like oh I
want a name that's like mine but not
mine and one of her sister's names was
June and so that's we took that from
June was a very my family was like
wealthy growing up before we lost it all
right but we had our own family
Carpenter our construction guy his name
was June he was our bundai really was he
hot um he was not but um did he try to
bang you uh I remember I had to make a
diarama and with paper mâché and he was
like hold my beer we you're not going to
do it paper mâché and him and my dad
created like this [__] like it was
like a it wasn't even a diarama it was
like the rice terorist of the
Philippines but in I don't know how you
call it it was like a 3D beautiful thing
they made and I went to school that day
and I was like look what I made and no
one obviously belied I made it but my
dad and my Carpenter June Bund oh my God
I was very surprised at how you said
diarama the way that I say it and then
you immediately said mâché word paper
mâché Mas thank you for saying that how
do you wild mâché mâché you say [__] so
C you say I don't want to hear [__]
she's called Caper cant which is like
what her character would yeah but you
know it's like the Philippines it's like
wrong emphasis on the wrong salable as
our like Olympic sport basically it is
funny though 2024 go I'm going to eat my
popcorn and watch um my 2024 goals um I
touched on it earlier um I am starting
um I am leaning into my entrepreneur
side and I am launching something that
we could probably talk about pretty soon
I'm super excited about it it's right up
my alley um something that I fully
believe in and so stay tuned for that
and so it's a big year for me and I'm
super excited and you're you're in
love oh on a personal front on a
personal front yeah yeah a little bit of
that I don't want to like jinx it am I
allowed to say that yes that I like you
know I'm like smitten and stuff oh yes
of course you're allowed to say that
okay I feel I feel who would not let you
who is the person that would not let you
Bobby I don't want this to get back to
him no no no yeah I am I am a little bit
smitten I think that um this person
might be exactly like what I've been
needing like my whole life oh my gosh
it's too soon to tell yeah like how can
you know is he perfect or is he a
narcissist it's really too soon to tell
KY you have trauma you know I know I'm
always waiting for the other shoe to
drop I just was saying that to my friend
and I was like I no longer feel that way
I'm like not I no longer am allowing
that feel feeling I should good yeah I
should just lean into the to the joy of
all yeah let it let the shoe drop as a
surprise don't anticipate it no no shoe
dropping that's um um what my therapist
said she's like they did a study where
it's like people who worried and people
who didn't worry and they it doesn't
change the outcome it doesn't change the
pain of the outcome when you worry or if
you don't worry about it so so time
you're wasting so much energy worrying
because it's going to hurt just as much
even if you feel like you've prepared
Yourself by worrying I need to really
remember that yeah Annie 2024 where you
at comedy
special exciting I don't know exactly
when but it's all coming together I'm
like so excited I figured out what my
closer is and it's like so epic and I'm
so excited so I'm like I've been like
writing it backwards can I go to the
taping yes can I wait do we know when
and where oh um only one only one slug
only one slug no I don't know I don't
know when and where yet but um but the
part that I care about the most which is
the actual jokes of it all I'm like it's
all coming together and I'm so excited
and you've come a long fing way when I
met you it was like Hey I'm you know
just moving from my car to an actual uh
you know with something with a roof on
it so rich and look how far you've come
no I feel really good I feel excited I
feel like I'm really like getting it
might not look like it but I am getting
on top of my finances and stuff like
that I'm figuring everything out and I'm
just being like a grownup and it's like
really fun and I don't know I look
forward to like more things more
experiences but I'm really excited about
my special that's a big deal and um it's
a huge deal you're beating Bobby to
it I he's a precautionary tale he's a
precautionary tail because I could just
never do a special to but I I feel like
I'm I'm ready and I'm excited and yeah
I'm really excited about right no better
time than now I think Now's the Time for
you and then I'm just to continue like
getting all my [__] done it's just been
so fun to like actually get things done
and you know I want to write a book
there's like a lot of things I want to
do that I actually am tackling now and
it seems realistic where before it was
like like like a pipe dream right learn
to read like I think I think the the
moral of the moral of at least my life
story is like remember the original
Dream cuz sometimes I think along the
way you you get things like and now
you're making money and then somehow
you're like I'm still not satisfied and
it's like imagine if you had reported
back to that
girl in your mid2 and said hey this is
what you're doing she would Dr Drew's
cell phone number and I can text him not
that he likes it at very odd hours of
the night is like I mean there's so many
things that are like so crazy I can't
believe it I know Dr Drew was someone
that I listened to as a very lonely girl
with who couldn't understand why she was
as depressed as she was who didn't
understand that the sexual trauma she
endured you know was was making her want
to kill herself myself and I was there
in a small room in Pasadena listening to
this man's voice and now he is someone
that I can text we have the Love Line
number the personal love line number
it's crazy do you want it our patreon
you guys that's how I feel about you
guys just so you know my first text that
I got from all of you I almost cried in
the same way where it's like I used to
watch you and was like so excited too
eager I'm just kidding oh that's sweet
love you it's so sweet Stella you should
just know that do about yourself is like
it's such that was a cool moment it does
feel like amazing
to meet these like sluggy and just see
it's exciting it's exciting I think that
this show like the the greatest thing
I've gotten out of it is like I've
really reached like a very like specific
dream audience that I've always wanted
to have and people that are kind of like
wanting to like grow and get over
[__] and laugh and have a good time
and not like be like bogged down by the
past or whatever not to make it sound
very boring but you know what I mean and
more iasa this year what do we have here
Stella this is from I thought that this
is a anything is ego death oh well Katie
and I were talking about
how like the concept of an ego death if
someone's like I've had an ego death and
they still have an ego because they're
like acknowledging their ego what you
know what ego what is ego death yeah
look her up and read it out okay and I
know we're in a really like positive um
space right now but I do do want to talk
about the one bad one of the worst
memories I've had of 2023 that I want
erased from my mind and um that is um
being punched in the back of the head
outside of a strip club what and I don't
think I ever told you I'm sorry I'm
sorry I punched you I didn't know it was
you I I told you guys this story so I
know that we you know we're making plans
to have maybe your baby shower at a
shrip club right Esther or as you know
we're having some like team building um
thing happening at a strip club um but
yeah I try to break up a fight outside
of the strip club and between like
between who okay it was between you're
not going to believe this it sounds like
premeditated believe I W I go into a
strip club with a guy that I'm seeing
and in that strip club is a fullblown b
uh like a batch party a bachelor party
and there was some guy that I used to
see I immediately was like uh we got to
get out of here I went over to the guy I
used to see I was like hi hey good to
see you but I told the guy I was seeing
I was like we need to get out of here
cuz like people are drinking there's
lots of testosterone I'm the only girl
current guy and so we moved to another
strip club literally 20 minutes after
that same bachelor party comes into that
strip club and at that point I'm like
what what am I going to do and so I
leave I was like you know the night is
over I'm just going to leave so there's
no drama and um the guy that I'm seeing
was like no problem like I'm not trying
to start [__] either so he walks ahead
of me and I walk behind him and the guy
that I used to see comes after me and he
was like I want to talk to you cuz he's
not like you know he's like the MD strip
club club crawl he's hurt about it he
wasn't like being like aggro about it
but he was like hurt and you know one of
my other guy friends who was there not
the guy I'm seeing comes over and he was
like hey he's like everything okay like
we need to [__] go and so then it's
like the Spider-Man meme but it's all
guys that are in love with
Kila they squared up and I was like No
And I got sandwiched and you guys I got
fing I got thrown in the kumate like I
haven't like been in that kind of scrap
in like but I got punched in the back of
the head that guy that I used to date
and um the friend of the guy that I'm
seeing and that but dude they were not
paying attention to me I kept catching
blows like stray blows to my head they
were like fighting each other and I kept
trying to like their masculinity like
over road that they were like fighting
over you they were like both trying to
protect you and exactly I was like this
is over me but somehow you guys keep
punching me like I do like a head
punching there's something about a head
punching that's so funny dude I got I
got my bell Rong I haven't been punched
in the side of the head it was like the
back of my head and I got like pushed to
a wall it was so [__] pathetic and
sad and I'm like I am and you're
probably dressed so cute too so cute my
little cowboy boots do you know how
embarass in it is to get thrown across a
parking lot in a cute outfit Esther your
life is just like so much more thrilling
than it's not mine it's not but this was
really like I would like to forget this
memory of 2023 well you got to get
punched one more time to forget it get
punched in the front and the back at the
same time I got to get my teeth knocked
out in
2024 don't I like your teeth don't put
your
teeth I to forget I want to forget my
first trimester forever I don't ever
want to go back I that was the worst
time of my life I want to forget for
sure just because of how sick you were
so sick so sad in bed all day a huge day
for me was like going from the bed to
the couch getting that tissue and
shoving it in your disgusting slobbery
mouth so sad it was I'll say maybe what
I want to forget is when you couldn't
announce it was I was like this is
driving crazy I want to there's so many
things I really did feel bad for you
Esther you were like constantly like
foing at the mouth really weird it was
so bad you're just like a oh a sick
puppy yeah I had a perfect year sucks
sucks for you guys sucks for you guys
you got punched in the uterus you got
punched in the head I've just
been oh you really aren't going to say
like one bad memory perfect I literally
can't I'm not even kidding I can't think
of one there's been like is you know but
I I everything's been good kly can you
go back to your ambient anal I'm sorry
I'm so interested and because I'm not an
anal girl and I I'm not either that's
why I had I needed an ambient what what
do you want to know about anal ambient
Stella this is getting a little personal
no should I be I thought now we know
that you're a little butt pirate I'm
just wondering is it because she's a
little butt pirate at se just trying to
find the right butt pirate is so I am so
scared of anyone touting my butt but um
I'm wondering if it was because you were
relaxed or is it because like you like
what was it yeah I was I was high TW she
was too busy tweeting racist things she
wasn't paying attention no I think it
was because I just wasn't really in my
body which is really not ideal because I
think when you do try something like new
sexually you should be sober and you
know able to like you know consent to no
don't keep going actually I don't like
that and I think I was just too high to
even notice I mean I noticed but it was
like oh maybe this I was just confused I
was high and confused she I was seeing
Stars she got punched in the back of the
head
she took an Ami and then she got knocked
in the back of the head guys I don't
want to be punched in the head this year
I want to show my skims off my new skims
that I want more skims in the New Year
oh yeah let's manifest that for sure wow
it's the whole set I love this how
[__] cute is this really cute my
horoscope said my horoscope said for
this year that I should wear brown oh
okay the reason I wanted to talk about
egod death guys was just so I could talk
about you know I listen to all these
goobers and stuff and I love like eard
tole and I love like I all these things
but I'm like how rich is he what do you
mean like how like can you have an ego
death if you're like if you have like
multiple houses if you have $70 million
and I want the answer to be yes because
that's where I'm headed I mean that's
sort of always what I thought about like
you know like deepok Chopra always had
his moment and everyone and that was
like everyone's like Guru and go-to guy
for the longest time different from
mearth cuz I think he really is like
legit yeah yeah deepok I remember Bobby
being like he was in a CA F in San Diego
one time and like he tipped so little
and I'm
like how can you be that guy and then be
that cheap or not be considerate to
weight staff you think his his like his
excuse was like well I want to empower
them to be ter I tip so much like I'm
telling you I have a meeting with my
business manager and I think he's going
to be like you have to tip less you're
being crazy but I just like to my friend
I had a whole conversation with her
about this we went to a donation-based
um breath work
and there was a breath work before it
that also had acupuncture in it so it
cost $45 to go to that one and that one
the time didn't work out that's the one
I wanted to go to so then I went to this
donation based one so I had in my head
the idea of $45 already and the guy that
runs it is very sweet and he just wanted
to put it together for people that can't
afford to do uh it was a sound bath that
can't afford to do these type of things
in LA and and so afterwards I showed her
like cuz I wrote a funny like voice like
memo on the venmo and she was like whoa
you gave $40 she's like that should be
money that you're saving for your house
for your family and stuff like that and
I was like I guess I just don't and
maybe this will make me bankrupt or
something uh and thank you for rebag I
can just sell the purses again but um I
like to think of it like an overflow of
abundance and but it just to me it was
like a very easy thing to do $40 but she
really kind of got in my head that that
that's money for and I've had friends
that are like I don't give people not
that they don't tip but they don't like
overtip because they're like that's
money that could be for my family m I
think that there's like either way what
do you guys think I think everyone's
financial situation is different and
like it's so hard to judge what people
are doing I think obviously you have to
tip like I would say 25 20 to
25% like it's just kind of the usual
like for me that's easier to just go by
a percent as opposed to like what mood
am I in like I just kind of always do
that but I don't judge someone that says
to you like like oh that's for my family
like I I don't judge that she said it
it's for my family but the other girl
yeah oh yeah so I don't know I know it
was weird it was just interesting cuz I
was like oh it's just not the way I like
Vibe j i i don't judge how other people
that I'm not dating tip but if I'm
interested in a guy and I am absolutely
looking at how he tips I want a fat tip
I want I want to I want to I want to
give fat tips I want people at my table
to give fat tips I go to this coffee
shop every day and I chat with all the
people obviously and that's where I got
you the shirt and um I tip them you know
how you can tip like they give you like
three options of tips I always tip the
highest one it's like $3 on like a$2
thing it's like I just always do that
I'm talking to them I'm taking up their
time like whatever I do the same thing
and then there's a guy who talks to them
just the same amount as me and they told
me he never tips get the out of it yeah
you tip nothing get out of there don't
talk to them yeah that's very in out
[__] if you're not gonna tip don't
don't chat take their time and he's not
as entertaining as me listen I'm coming
in with some good bits okay I've I've
stepped over 20 homeless people doing
knitting doing weird [__] on the street
it's wild in my neighborhood I got some
stories by the time I get in there but
that's sort of what I love about you
though Annie like you really are very
very generous like I think you are
generous in a way that like you don't
hold it over people's heads like you
really are so happy to give it feels
very good it feels good to get I don't
know if it's because I have a twin or
something I don't know it's just always
I like to get people presents and it
doesn't matter I actually I mean I well
I I've learned to receive presents and
stuff but it was never like that was my
thing I don't know what I'm sure there's
some heal unhealthy reason for it but I
really just I really I don't know I like
to especially for people that are doing
a service handing me something like yeah
Annie I have a question for you related
to the iasa thing so when you go on
these like are men doing doing iasa and
like looking inward like are they
learning or is it mostly women okay it
was interesting though cuz I wore this
like this glowing dress the first night
and I I do like dress cute to the IAS
ceremony I do like wear my sung I like
come as big as possible um are you
supposed to dress comfortable though or
yeah but I dress comfy but like cute you
know and um I know I came in once in my
shamama was like no he's like it's too
tight he goes he's like you could wear
it but it's too I go you're right the
pants were too tight like could you do
an iasa journey in your outfit right now
or would you be like um this would be
too tight it feels like Free People this
would be too tight but maybe the pants
and but I have this like I have this
this skim thing hello I love you um
um um but it's like a blanket jacket
it's like a it's like a a
down like wrap blanket jacket I got I
don't know if they still sell them and
you tie it and it's like the most
amazing it's like perfect for it cuz you
can kind of make it a thing and but um
there was a guy so I wore this like
flowing dress that had like back list
area and you know at the end it kind of
we like all dancing and stuff and one
there's this Boston guy that I do it
with this older guy and he's like busted
my balls a little bit and was like I'm
trying to do iasin you're I got to deal
with you dancing in that outfit or
whatever like Jesus Christ but he was
being so funny about it and then there
was a Romanian guy that was there and he
was like yes uh we I am sexually
deprived and to see a woman like that is
D and it was he was being so crazy I was
like whoa Andrew Tate chill I was like
dude I'm dressing cuz it's comfortable
for me it just was like nice for me and
later I made a joke to like a group of
the like it was men and women all
outside and I made some joke I was like
you know I really want to honor men I
like love men so much because you guys
are so incredible you're so [__]
stupid but also know everything and it's
like so incredible to be both of those
things and I was literally just kidding
and everyone laughed and then that
Romanian guy was like later came out to
me he's like you said that thing about
men and I was like what the hell but
then by the end of it he was like way
different do you know what I mean yeah
that's interesting like he was like
struggling with his like masculinity or
whatever yeah I'm just wondering like
Bill bur talks about when he took
shrooms and like had an experience I
feel like I just don't hear about it as
much I feel hear more about it from
women and no there's a lot of guys crazy
is that like I don't know because when I
did the the ketamine it wasn't so much
like an ego death I honestly genuinely
thought I was like it was just death I I
felt like I was like passing away I was
like I'm not going to make it out of
this oh my gosh yeah so how many do you
know I just got my mind Bloom and it's
like I got how many I got 9 I got 950
milligrams I'm excited yeah it's about
yeah but it's the int going to space
yeah well happy
2024 everyone hope it's going well
already yes we are so happy to have
another year with all of our sluggy and
we have a big live show coming up
February 13th we can't wait to see you
at that here in LA it's probably sold
out by now who knows um and yeah we'll
see you guys next week with a brand new
[Music]
episode